نقل مراسل الجزيره عن قيادي في الجبهه
الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين القياده العامه ان
خمسه افراد من الجبهه قتلوا وجرح سبعه
اخرون في غاره اسرائيليه على احدى مواقع
الجبهه عند الحدود اللبنانيه السوريه وقال
المصدر ان الغاره نفذت صباح اليوم
واستهدفت مركزا عسكريا في منطقه قوسايا
عند الحدود اللبنانيه السوريه شرقيه سهله
البقاع اللبناني وادت كذلك الى اصابه
اليات تابعه للجبهه عند مدخل احد انفاق
الموقع وخسائر ماديه لم يحددها
معنا من بيروت مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
ايهاب ما الذي عرف حتى الان عن هذه الغاره
من تفاصيل وتداعياتها
هي غار اسرائيليه وفقا للمصدر المسؤول في
الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
وقعت قرابه الواحده والنصف فجرا هذا اليوم
واستانفت موقعا تابعا للقياده العامه في
منطقه قصايا وهي منطقه حدوديه بين لبنان
وسوريا في شرق سهل البقاع اللبناني هذه
الغاره ادت الى مقتل خمسه افراد وجرح سبعه
اخرين وفقا للمصدر في الجبهه الشعبيه الذي
لم يحدد طبيعه الاصابات الماديه الاخرى
التي وقعت في هذا الموقع الغاره استهدفت
احد المداخل للانفاق تابعه للجبهه الشعبيه
والموقع هو عباره عن شبكه انفاق معقده تقع
في منطقه قصايا ولها امتدادات في الجانب
اللبناني والجانب السوري اعني بها الانفاق
هذه الغاره استهدفت اليات كانت
تقف عند احد مداخل هذا الموقع لم يتحدد
طبيعتها بعد لكن الصور التي بثتها القياده
العامه تظهر
حدوث حفره عميقه عند مدخل احد الانفاق هذه
المنطقه كانت ايضا بغاره اسرائيليه عام
2019 لم تؤدي حينها الى وقوع اصابات بين
صفوف عناصر الجبهه الشعبيه القياده العامه
التي لها ارتباطات وثيقه على المستوى
السياسي والعسكري مع
القياده السوريه وتحديدا النظام السوري
وايضا مع حزب الله عمليا هذه المنطقه هي
منطقه حدوديه فيها هذه فيها هذا الموقع
التابع للجبهه الشعبيه وهو موقع رئيسي
بالنسبه اليها لدى الجبهه الشعبيه القياده
العامه مواقع اخرى في لبنان في منطقه لوسي
في سهل البقاع اللبناني وفي منطقه تقع جنو
ب العاصمه بيروت وتحديدا في منطقه النعمه
ايهاب العقد مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
بيروت شكرا لك على هذه المعلومات